and of course everyone like every girl's
in this world we all want to get like
prettier Korean society is making uma
look like Barbie dolls plastic surgery
advertisements everywhere outside on the
streets on buildings in buses and
subways how could an individual woman
growing up and living in this society
not feel pressured to look perfect
everything literally everything around
you says looking beautiful is the only
thing that matters you do to be alive if
we say that beauty does not matter
people invented the beauty standards and
we provide the answer for people's needs
this is how it works
[Music]
South Korea one of the world's most
prosperous nations home to kpop Samsung
Electronics and Kia Motors it's also
been called the plastic surgery capital
of the world where tourists flocked to
the high states neighborhood of Gangnam
to sample an array of cosmetic
procedures one of those patients is Aria
a 25 year old Thai woman who has been
living and working in Korea for five
years
today she's come to JW plastic surgery
center in Seoul to get double eyelid
surgery a procedure that creates an
eyelid crease that around half of East
Asian people are born without I am going
to have my surgery and lateral
canthoplasty
and come to class day first of all it
will make my life a bit easier at first
like when I'm wake up in the morning I
won't have to spend my time to put like
a pilot a to make my I even and it will
easier to put a makeup on of course and
for besides that of course like when you
make people eyes is the first thing that
you see when you're talking to people
and sometime I feel like really not
confident about it when I'm looking to
and other people because sometimes they
like keep staring at your eyes that you
have a symmetric guy something like that
Aria isn't alone a 2015 study revealed
that almost one in three young women
have had plastic surgery in South Korea
that's thirty one percent of women
between the ages of 19 and 29 Korea also
ranks fifth in the world for its number
of trained plastic surgeons making up
5.3 percent of the world total in modern
societies in Asia there is kind of it's
tricky because it's not quite an
aspiration to look Western but I think
that a lot of the Western beauty ideals
have influenced beauty beauty trends in
East Asia so for example like large
double eyelids or large large eyes with
double eyelids to have like a slim nose
with the tall bridge a smaller kind of
v-line shaped face all those kinds of
things I know a lot of people who have
surgery like half yeah more than half of
all the girls in my class in high school
got plastic surgery as a graduation gift
[Music]
welcome to my lair this is my dog this
is Summerlee she's part of a growing
radical feminist movement called escape
the corset
they are rebelling against what they see
as careers impossible beauty standards
[Music]
I'm using a fake name because being a
feminist in Korea can be dangerous
apparently it's a good enough reason to
get fired from your job or receive
threats online and I am currently
participating in off the corset movement
the corset is a representation of
femininity that we perform such as the
expectations of women having long hair
or no body hair or wearing makeup
having fair soft skin wearing high heels
wearing feminine clothes all of those we
call corsets and we reject doing that we
reject wearing those because it does
nothing good for a woman's rights like I
did it I wore makeup I had long hair and
they wore dresses from time to time but
I always thought it was exhausting time
cuz you mean money consuming and before
I used to look in the mirror so often
because I had to check my makeup
constantly I was so conscious about how
I looked because that's what makeup does
it starts with looking in the mirror
looking at your face and finding out
flaws to cover or fix but since I don't
do that anymore I'm less conscious about
how I look I don't care about how I look
I feel very free so escape corset I'm
its
of the main movements now that is kind
of at the forefront of Korea's feminist
movements the name comes from petrol
Cosette
which means touch treatment means escape
in Korean the movement first arose
summer of 2018 when on social media some
Korean women started to destroy their
makeup in a series of videos and
pictures not only did they destroy their
makeup but they also cut their hair
short to say that you can't have short
hair as a women but also that they no
longer wanted to be objectified or
sexualized while more and more women are
taking part and escape the corset it's
also been met with some resistance by
men who feel threatened and think the
movement is hateful towards men in the
song feminist by controversial rapper
son II he appears to mock the escape the
corset movement with lyrics like when
did we ever say you needed to be pretty
you did plastic surgery for your own
satisfaction now you're being childish I
like long hair don't change son he
released an apology for the son
insisting it was satire and not his
personal views on women's rights but he
then caused controversy again by calling
radical feminists mentally sick at one
of his concerts with older generations I
think it's still harder for them to
reconcile with like the rise of such a
movement and then there are segments of
men who obviously feel that these types
of movements are disadvantaging men in
general some of them are called meninist
s-- and there are counter movements
being led by men that are male
I guess forms of male empowerment
Rowen limb is a college student who is
also taking part in the escape the
corset movement
she runs a YouTube channel recreating
dance routines from kpop videos taking
away any elements she sees a sexually
objectifying I think all artists are
responsible for social development so
whenever I dance I think about it I
think a pop culture has several times
more to pick them it's Mary
it's so influential so so influential
especially for minors oommen in korea
love male I talk so much that they pour
money and pour affection on them and fit
themself into a mold of abnormal
appearance and even though they are
alert they try to look like children
Korean woman cut their hair and offer
received a question do you want to be a
man but also many women in Korea are
trying to escape from the mythical power
of beauty from breaking away from the
organization with long hair the two-step
objectification of a man
they absolutely have a right to protest
whatever makes them happy I think it is
a human right but it is not only way to
the soul I strongly oppose them judging
those women who decided to still wear
makeup or on double plastic surgery if
someone feels burdened by beauty
standards and wants to stop it's their
right to protest it should be a personal
matter
if a woman wants to adjust a beauty
centered or was just stand against
loving themselves as they are we are not
allowed to judge neither sighs I think
the women in South Korea it is our
desire to get plastic surgery that is a
phenomenon and younger looking and
better looking
since Korean world our economy developed
so fast and then neoliberal consumerism
actually just pressurized hip
so all the practice of a body
multiplication including the plastic
surgery makeup and diets disease they
believe is still showing hair Hill
identity in the society Dada
took away like five minutes less than
five minutes I don't know one thing that
really made me snap and made me feel
like I really have to do this is when I
saw an advertisement of school uniforms
one brand made an advertisement and for
the boys uniforms they highlighted how
comfortable it is how warm it is how
adjustable the size is so that a rapidly
growing boy can wear it for three years
and for the girls school uniform they
highlighted how tiny you would look in
that how slim you would look at that how
pretty the skirt line is designed they
had a little pocket that would only fit
a lipstick like the size of two fingers
maybe and they proudly advertised it as
a lipstick pocket like tada we have a
pocket for a lipstick media when the
West tends to exaggerate the meaning of
beauty in Korean society but I
personally think that Korean people just
speak about it more openly Westerners
say that inside the beauty is the most
important if that is the case then why
Kardashians are so popular on Instagram
who are why people almost approve the
Susan Boyle before seeing her
performance on Britain's Got Talent
people always ever wanted to look
beautiful people are also judged by the
appearance whether we may like it or not
this is human nature beautiful people
might achieve a life course more easily
it's not only about the appearance is
also or above all about the confidence
the worst misconception I think is that
Asian people want to look more Western
we do not follow Western Beauty standard
small eyes make us look tired or somehow
unfriendly this is why double eyelid is
considered to be a beauty standard small
of will I face is considered to be
beautiful it gives smooth and pleasant
look people judge people by their looks
and there is nothing we can do with them
it is a very first impression of a
person and this is not something our
mythical evil industry has invented so
we're gonna take a quick walk around my
area I love I love wearing pants back
[Music]
clearly there are a growing number of
people beginning to redefine what it
means to be beautiful in Korea but for
the vast majority the pursuit of
perfection shows little sign of slowing
down
and so there's bound to be more backlash
coming against these types of ideals
because as demonstrated in other
societies they can end up becoming quite
constricting and suffocating for a lot
of people men and women I see a lot of
people who seem to be participating and
off the corset movement but I also want
us like being in this state to be
considered normal I'm never going back
to the feminine summer this is feminine
I'm a woman what a woman is and what a
woman does is feminine
[Applause]
[Music]